Stuart Rose thank you so much for coming
on the show this week now you are the
chair of a massive retailer you have
been a retailer for five decades in
various different businesses we know
that this is the most important period
of the year for retail Christmas how
much do you think
people are being affected at the moment
with belt tightening because of the cost
of living crisis not spending on
presence on the little extras that they
normally buy this time of the year
there's some Beth it's kind of you to
remind people how long I've been around
I have been around the block a bit but
um I'm one of the few people around
still working who can remember the last
time we had serious inflation in the
serious financial crisis back in the mid
late 70s and this is a tough Christmas
people are really really seeing the
Australian we haven't had inflation like
this for 40 odd years it's something
that people are not used to dealing with
and it's having a real very real effect
on everybody across the piece sad that
at the moment in the first Christmas
that we've had no covid that the lights
are on people are wanting to get out and
about that we've actually got this this
difficulty and then on top of that we've
got all the difficulties with strikes
and have you noticed that people are
just not spending as much listen um we
do a survey at Asda which I'm chairman
where we know that 20 of households in
the the UK are running a 60 pound a
month deficit 20 of all UK households
now some of those will be as the
customers and some will be other
customers but if you're living like that
it's very tough people are making tough
choices so what we'll see is that people
I think will want a good Christmas
they'll want to have a nice celebration
on the day they'll want to look after
their children but they're being very
thoughtful about what they can afford
and what they can't afford so Stu you're
saying that according to your surveys
one in five households are running a
monthly deficit so they get to the end
of the month and they're in debt
that's quite frightening because that
builds up Beth without interrupting you
it's shocking what do you mean it's
shocking well it's shocking that we live
in in a place like that today that there
are one-fifth of our households who are
struggling and I've seen it myself in
stores people come into the counter to
detail and saying well actually I've now
spent my 25 on my 30 pounds on my 40
pounds that I've allocated for myself
each week and you know don't put any
more through the till and we're seeing
that so people will cut back they'll
look after the children they'll have fun
with the family but of course they know
that in January they've got all the
bills to pay and they've got all the
extra costs surrounding the utilities
and whatever else and inflation is yet
to slow down and Stuart you you just go
back to your long career I mean you and
I have known each other for a couple of
decades when I was a you can say that I
can't I was a retail reporter at the
financial times you were at the time the
chief executive and then executive
chairman of Marks and Spencers and you
have worked for five decades in food
retail and clothing retail at the
biggest brands in this country
and you touched on it that about the the
1970s and 80s when inflation was in the
high teens and then of course the
financial crash of 2008 how
does this compare have you seen anything
as bad in your lifetime in your career
is what you're seeing and faced with now
well we've had four sort of what can I
call them that Black Swan events one
possibly we could have control but you
know you pointed out that we had the uh
the global financial crisis we had
brexit we've had covid we've now got the
war in Ukraine these are the things
which are largely outside our control
although one of them was in our control
and uh with the same time now we have
got within the global Supply chains
we've got complete disruption so yes
inflation which we've not seen the era
of inflation the era of cheap money
cheap money is gone inflation is here
and that's why it's so important just as
we had to do back in the 70s that we
first and foremost kill inflation we
must kill inflation because you know
I've said it before and others have said
it it's very very corrosive it erodes
wealth and of course it hits the so it
hits the the poorer off worse than it
hits those that were better off and I'm
going to come on to sort of inflation
and wages and those sorts of issues but
before I do you talked about one in five
households not been able to pay their
bills shouldn't we begin you said it was
shocking and it is shocking but at the
same time disposable income is falling
it will continue to fall as costs go up
and taxes rise I know inflation is set
to Peak and then Fall by the beginning
by the end of next year but we're in
this for the Long Haul aren't we this
isn't going to be
a return to better living standards
within 12 months for example for lots of
families well I I sort of half agree
with you I just think there may be a
little opportunity here that we mustn't
Miss first of all you're quite right I
mean since the austerity of following
the global financial crisis people have
in real terms had less money to spend
we've now seen a situation where you
have got inflation running at whatever
it is 11 you've got private sector
settlements running about six percent
six point two percent and you've got
public sector settling at about two
percent so there's a mismatch there yeah
people are worse off now I believe that
you know we can get inflation under
control I believe it's an imperative
that we do so mathematically it will
anniversaries it will start coming down
if we can get through this very painful
hump and don't get me wrong it's painful
for everybody particularly the lower
paid and not be caught up in this wage
uh price spiral which might happen if
we're not careful then I think that
towards the back end of 23 we might just
see easier times but it's going to be
very very tough and I think Jeremy Hunt
said that a couple of days ago so just
to be clear Stuart I mean on the one
hand you're saying that you can see that
public sector pay settlements are not
matching in any way where the private
sector is coming out but you're also
saying that
to try and match where the private
search is is dangerous potentially or
not a good idea because that creates an
inflationary spiral you do you do you do
accept that or that's what your view is
we have to look at each one of these
people who are having strikes each one
of these unions who are calling strikes
the moment we need to look at every case
on a case-by-case basis I'm not going to
go into the detail of who I think has
got the better case and the worst case
but some people are you know pushing it
a little bit harder than perhaps they
should and some people do deserve these
Rises so it's not a question of who
deserves a rise it's a question how much
can we afford to give people and when
can we afford to do it and if we all
just take a little bit of thoughtfulness
or give a bit of thoughtfulness about
the implications if we get it wrong then
we might just end up at the right place
so I'm not asking people to sacrifice
I'm asking people to be thoughtful so do
you think the rail workers are pushing
it in the nurses aren't well I'm going
to leave you to draw your own
conclusions but people you know the
Great British problems said the other
day that you thought narcissists deserve
to pay rise because nurses definitely
reserve a pay rise but you know at the
end of the day nurses are asking for a
big double-digit increase now you have
to ask yourself is that affordable the
answer is in the current state of the
National Health Service it probably
isn't so can we get to a compromise and
you know I know that the the nursing
Union don't want to fight hard for their
for the nurses and I absolutely support
that I used to be married to a nurse in
my first marriage but at the end of the
day you know we have to realize that you
can't you know you can't uh you can't
have everything we'll find a question on
that and then we'll move on just just to
go back to that I mean the nurses are
asking for a big double-digit rise but
they also said to the government that
they were prepared to go back to the
table to negotiate the implication being
perhaps they would accept a smaller pay
increase and the government won't budge
is that the wrong decision do you think
by the government I don't know what took
place yesterday something took place
yesterday there was apparently a midi uh
the the the the leader of the nurses
Union said that it was a waste of time
effectively and I don't know what came
out of the government side but you know
I do believe genuinely in any
circumstance like this there is no
substitute for people sitting down there
has to be a compromise at some point in
time we all have sympathy for people who
are hard up and need to catch up on
their wages but at the end of the day
you know we have lost more days in
strikes uh this month I believe that we
have lands for 15 or 20 years and I am
somebody who uses the trains I am
somebody who sees what's happening out
there and I think this is not
sustainable now the government's got a
responsibility but so do the people in
the workforce have a responsibility
we've all got a little pile in a little
bit and Stuart you you're also very
privileged man
um you've been a very successful
businessman you still are being the
chair of Asda during this period has it
been an eye-opener for you
well not just being chair of Asda listen
I'm being used to being at the front of
retail all my life and I see and I see
those people who are well healed and
I've seen those people who are less well
healed what good retailers need to do
and I think actually
um Supermarket retailing over the last
six or nine or twelve months has shown
its best side all the supermarkets but
I'd like to believe ours has also been
doing more than its bid I've been
working hard to make sure we lean in to
help customers I mean we've all very
much swallowed some of the price
increases coming through I suspect all
of us will end up making less net margin
than we made last year all of us are
facing headwinds in terms of costs
whether it's Carriage Insurance Freight
utilities and of course wages and I
think that we're all putting initiatives
in place so in ASDA you know we have put
in a locked and drop but we've
guaranteed pricing for a year or so we
have put in our plan where young kids
can go and get a meal for a pound we've
put in our free meal we put in a a deal
for over 60 year olds where we've had a
million over 60 year olds come in and
they can eat soup bowl of soup in a roll
and a cup of tea or coffee for a pound
we're trying to do what we can to help
them in every way but
you know it's not an infinite pot
but this goes back to my point about
wage claims because as wage claims come
through the danger is that we get the
wage spiral we get the price increase
viral and then that gets passed on
another time but you are you saying
Stuart that I used to asda's profits
will take a hit this year as you absorb
some of the the price pressures instead
of passing on to the consumers I'm not
here to give a profit forecast for
asthma or indeed anybody else but all of
us will be working hard very very hard
to try and ameliorate the pressures
coming towards us and I suspect that
we're all going to find it very
difficult but this is not about making
profit in this year this is about making
sure that we keep our faith with our
customers and in asda's case
you know this is a company that is a
very large Beast we're actually the
third largest but we've got aspirations
for the second largest we want to do our
bit to make sure the customers recognize
and be given the right value the right
prices and the right service and you can
only do that by making sure that when
they come in they're happy and satisfied
and delighted with what they get and
Stuart you you mentioned that that you
you've got a scheme at the moment where
parents can go in they don't have to
spend anything if they can't afford it
but they can get a meal hustle cold for
their child at an Asda for a pound I
didn't realize you're also doing that
for elderly people as well what sort of
take-up are you seeing both from
families and from elderly people massive
I mean people are all looking for help
you know in every way we can so
everything we do but we're trying to
help our staff you know we obviously try
and do promotions for our staff we're
trying to help the blue light workers
they get a 10 deal from us at the moment
we're trying to help in local
communities where we're saying look
we've got small funds you can apply for
if you need a bit of extra help with
your heating for your local community or
your community meeting place or whatever
or whatever but
yeah and other retailers are doing
similar things we can't do everything
yeah but what we can do is be sincere in
our intent and be sincere in trying to
say to our customers look we know how
tough it is out there and you're seeing
it in buying patterns people are buying
more own label than some of the the
premium brands people are cutting back
on some of the luxuries people are
eating less basket sizes have been going
down uh but that you know so if you can
help them in any way in that Journey we
will try and do that as is currently the
third largest supermarket chain in the
UK do ministers meet with you to discuss
the cost of living difficulties people
are facing and about how government and
business together might be able to
better help people do you have those
conversations what do you just do it off
your own back I'm non-executive chairman
so I don't have an executive capacity in
the business a sense but Management in
ASDA do have contacts of course we do uh
with politicians particularly on a local
basis I think it's fair to say and you
know I I the relationship between
government and business in the last two
or three years has been pretty Rocky
it's been pretty up and down it's good
to see uh under the new Premiership now
that we've got you know Beginnings Now
sort of let's build some bridges
um it's the same as what we're seeing in
terms of the labor party in terms of
what they've put out in terms of the new
Manifesto and politics so people are now
working what we haven't got and what we
need to have and this is what's been the
real problem if I might say so British
politics really I suppose since the
brexit decision post-brexit all the
infighting that's been going on is we
haven't made some of the long-term
decisions that we need to do what are we
doing about food security what are we
doing about making sure that we've got
you know the right Supply chains in
place what are we doing about making
sure we get deregulation as we've been
promised but we still haven't seen all
those sorts of things that's what
government should be doing Stuart why
was it pretty rocking up and down in the
past couple of years with business and
government well I don't have to remind
you what was it the previous prime
minister but three said I've lost
counter Family Practice you're correct
if it's prime minister but three I'm not
going to repeat it on TV but that's how
we felt the expletive business
and you you thought Boris Johnson was
bad for business then well I don't think
business was on his agenda they'd be
perfectly honest with you and at the end
of the day we have to remember we live
in a free market economy we live in a
capitalist Society we don't do any
better system than capitalism capitalism
is the creation of wealth we then have
to work out how to distribute that
wealth and we can have our arguments
about that but the short answer is if we
don't create wealth we can't create and
spend money on taxes or pay taxes create
infrastructure and build a better
Britain you you've obviously led many
businesses with with big workforces did
you think do you dislike Boris Johnson
you seem to dislike him or you don't
think he was a good leader well I have
to Beverly honest with you it's not a
question of like or dislike you know you
expect when you have a leader that your
leader to be a fit for purpose and I
perfectly don't I don't think that Boris
Johnson was fit for purpose whatever he
may claim that he got but brexit does a
huge majority he did get a huge majority
but you know we are paying the price for
some of the decisions that were not made
or were made by that government now some
will disagree with me but it's
interesting that I'm a concern served
appear and I say that
well I'm going to come on to politics in
a minute but before I do I just wanted
to say to you about the cost of living
crisis final question on that do you
think the governments are doing enough
at the moment or do you think they do
need to do more to help people
well I think the government is in a very
tricky position because you know it did
borrow 400 billion pound to pay for
covid now we could argue about how well
or not that money was spent it then got
this other big Crisis coming through and
it's trying its best I think to do what
they have done for some of the lower
paid and for some of those who are less
well-off I think has been very helpful
but the most important thing we must do
is just keep relentlessly going on on a
broad front to try and kill inflation if
we do that things will get better and
you neatly lead me on to my next
question before we move on to other
things about politics but
um public sector strikes this week we've
talked about that a bit at Asda the GMB
is balloting Staff about wages at your
stores you pay 10 pounds 10 an hour Audi
pays 10 pounds 50. are you going to
increase staff wages at Asda well I'm
not going to comment on that other than
to say and this is quite interesting
point you just make because first of all
there's a labor shortage secondly if you
go back at a point in time so you've
just picked a point in time and I could
tell you that a few months ago we were
top quartile payers
everybody has been changing their pay
rates at different times of the year it
just happens we now have moved down we
will have a conversation with our staff
in in the first quarter of 23 about next
year but two things yeah we gave us last
night an eye on eight percent this year
which is ahead of the uh private sector
wage settlements the second thing is
that the GMB don't actually have a
mandate to to negotiate with us on our
hourly paid staff but that's a separate
matter we will We recognize the
importance of our staff we've got 155
000 people we recognize the importance
of looking after them I think and I hope
that we can look them in the eye and say
look we've looked after this year so
it's more a case if it's just you
haven't done this it's a Time
negotiations because at the moment
you're the lowest paid yeah but I
promise you that if you'd gone back
three months ago we wouldn't have been
in that place it's just a timing issue
okay
um I've taken that I think they're going
to get a pay rise next year but I know
you can't do that uh on television they
will certainly get a pay rise next year
I can't tell you what that is okay
you're a conservative peer we just said
you were clearly unhappy about the trust
Administration you didn't much like
Boris Johnson you asked to trust public
to resign did you ever or do you ever
think about giving labor a look
um well isn't that my very dear friend
uh Lord miners who was a labor peer died
earlier this year and he always used to
tease me and say look you're not a
proper conservative Steward I'm a
conservative principal I call myself a
conservative with a small C uh I believe
in the free market economy and I believe
in conservatism I won't deny that I
haven't been slightly disillusioned by
what we have seen in the last three or
four years everybody knows and you know
I may not have had a great job of it but
I was you know involved in the in the
great debate about brexit I absolutely
accepted when we lost that that we lost
it but I don't believe and this is where
I've got a real gripe that day one after
that decision was made that we've made
the best of what we could have done so
here we are six years later you know our
trade with the EU has gone down we
haven't done trade deals with anybody
else we're still arguing about can we
get one with the Indians or can't we
we've given up pretty well on can we get
one with the US of a so these are real
issues and in the meantime we've got a
an economy which is struggling now
the most important thing after we kill
inflation is to get gross it's easy to
talk about how do we do it well actually
you I've seen some interviews that
you've done subsequently about brexit
you obviously were a leading figure a
leading business voice in the I was the
only one there was a very few people who
were repaired account unfortunately up
and put their heads above the power but
it was difficult for retailers wasn't it
because customers were divided and you
you associate politically in that that
better I'm sure I agree with you I think
that we are that was the argument
retelling there was the argument but
it's not just retailers business people
business people it doesn't matter what
debate you've got going on about what
and you know here we've got a debate
going on the motorbike immigration we've
got a debate going on about the Northern
Ireland protocol we've got a debate
going on about all sorts of things I
think business people because leadership
is a privilege with the privilege of
leadership comes the responsibility and
I think we have to take responsibility
for saying what we believe to be right
we can't just look around the corner and
say well I better not say that because
my upset part of my community but but
Stuart you've talked about it
subsequently you say you accept brexit
in principle you don't want to re-run
2016 but you're clearly unhappy about
how you think it's been implemented in
practice I interviewed the chancellor a
couple of weeks ago and I pointed out to
him about the four percent hit over the
medium turned to GDP to growth according
to the fiscal Watchdog Watchdog that
makes independent forecasts about the
economy he just said to me I don't
accept that figure it's a hundred
billion pounds worth of growth over the
medium term what do you think when a
politician when the chancellor says he
just doesn't accept the forecast so
therefore
doesn't accept that brexit has harmed
the economy what's your response to that
well I I didn't hear that that interview
but Jeremy Hunt's a very intelligent man
I respect most of what he said so I'm
quite surprised he said it I think he's
rubbish you can't ignore the facts now
we can always argue that I can take a
particular number at a particular point
of time and another particular number
another point of time and make the
statistics fall in the way that I want
them to but the reality is that we are
worse off we have not taken the benefits
yet of being dealt with significant
trade deals elsewhere we have not
deregulated we have not in any form or
fashion got the best advantage that we
thought we were going to get and we
haven't got all the other things that
were promised now
what hasn't happened yet
is that somebody hasn't said look
what we did in principle was right
because we wanted to get back our we
wanted to get back to Take Back Control
we wanted to set our own regulations we
wanted to be have our sovereignty back
fine it hasn't worked in the form that
it was sold well if it hasn't formed
worked in the way it was sold let's try
a modification of it now I also see it
well thank you well I mean
style deal where we have closer trading
I think it was Jeremy Hunt himself who
said in there if it's not a Norway deal
let's look at a Swiss deal let me just
slam slap down in about five minutes we
have to come to an arrangement with in
my view our European Partners which is a
better Arrangement that we've got now
just as we're going to have to come to
an arrangement with them about the
Northern Ireland protocol because you
can't just sit there looking at each
other as the world goes on just saying
well I'm not moving I'm not moving and
get nothing Stu can you name any brexit
opportunities that will make British
business better off than it was before
it left the EU well sadly you know one
of the interesting things is you've just
seen you've just seen us deregulated are
announced some deregulation on on the
financial markets front
many of the regulations I believe I'm
writing saying this many of them
regulations that we put in place that
were put in place in the last 25 30
years in The UU EU will were put in
place at the instigation of British
politicians
so the Europeans might say to us look a
lot of these regulations are perfectly
good regulations so why do not want to
get rid of them the other danger is that
if we do get rid of some of this stuff
we may get to a situation if we cut too
far that we actually allow ourselves not
to do the deals that we still should be
doing in Europe actually say well you
know we'll we'll we'll cut out what's
the word I'm the expression I'm looking
for
and that's the thing that worries me
we've got to be pragmatic we've got to
actually get to a point where what do
you want what do I want what's best for
the UK now these politicians these
politicians say what do you think it's
going to be okay in 20 years time
and it might take 20 years fine well
I'll definitely be dead my children my
children would be retired and your
grandchildren will be looking for jobs
so that's a long time to wait in the
world that doesn't wait you don't think
they're getting it right at the moment
okay so final question you didn't like
Liz truss you didn't like I know but as
well you didn't I've never met Liz trust
well you probably doesn't okay I
publicly called on Liz truster as I
didn't think she was fit for purpose I
don't think I was wrong you you you you
said yourself you didn't think Boris
Johnson was fit for purpose and you
don't think that the government have
executed brexit in a way that benefits
the economy could you vote for kirstama
in 2024 I will look very hard when I get
well the good news for those people who
are worrying about that I can't vote
because I'm a conservative peer I'm a
peer it's appears done oh okay it
appears don't vote but they ask that
question but I will look very hard at
what is on offer and what I would say to
people is even as a conservative look
what's on the market store a look what's
on Market stall B and make a choice but
make a choice an informed Choice make
sure you know the facts make sure you
know what you think could be delivered
make sure who's delivering it ask
yourself the question can these people
actually me not only talk the talk but
walk the walk and then make your
decision about what you vote for let's
see what happens and you're sitting on
the fence at the moment you're not sure
no I think that I think that we have I
first of all I've always been slightly
wary about not having a strong
opposition we haven't had strong
opposition for a long time so it's good
to see some proper opposition and that
will always sharpen the pencil of the
incumbent government the incumbent
government for all the reasons you know
better than I do have spent three or
four years fighting each other at the
cost of the UK PLC I firmly believe that
we have actually in a world that's
moving very fast in a world that's very
dangerous in a world where alliances are
being formed all over the place all the
time we have sat there and started
banging each other on the nose to what
purpose
okay Stuart Rose thank you very much